hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about some of the major differences
between asexual and sexual reproduction
these are the two major types of
reproduction that organisms use to
generate offspring now why is
reproduction important well reproduction
is one of the major characteristics of
life that is when you write down all of
the characteristics that are required
for something to be living reproduction
is one of them if you are interested in
learning about some of the other major
characteristics of life see my video on
that topic now we've talked about
asexual reproduction first asexual
reproduction is characterized by
offspring that are genetically identical
to the parents this means that the DNA
sequences in the parent are the same as
the DNA sequences in the offspring
except for any random mutations that may
have occurred during the DNA replication
process of course this is in contrast to
sexual reproduction where offspring are
genetically different from their parents
now let's talk about the reasons for
this the reasons that offspring are
genetically identical and asexual
reproduction is because of how the
reproduction proceeds that is the DNA of
a cell is replicated and in the self
divided for example binary fission in
bacteria is where you have a bacterial
parent cell that replicates its DNA
enlarges in size and then splits into
two cells if you're interested in
learning more about the process of
binary fission see my video on that
topic of course in sexual reproduction
offspring are genetically different
because there are two parents you have
gametes from a male and gametes from a
female that come together in the process
of fertilization for example in humans
this is when the female's egg is
fertilized by male sperm and so the
resulting offspring
gets half of their DNA from the mother
and half of their DNA from the father
this makes them genetically different
from either their mother or their father
back to a sexual production let's talk
about some of the pros and cons the
major Pro of asexual reproduction is
that no mate is needed bacterial cells
for example they can simply divide
whatever the environment is good for
reproduction they can divide and they
don't need to find a mate to do that of
course a con is reduced genetic variety
and of course I reduced genetic variety
is because the offspring are genetically
identical to the parent cells again with
the exception of any random mutations
that happen during the DNA replication
process pros and cons for sexual
reproduction the pro is increased
genetic variety this is because the
offspring have half of their DNA from
their mother half of their DNA from
their father as well as any genetic
mutations there arose during the DNA
replication process that led to the
gametes that were used in the
reproductive process a con of sexual
reproduction is that an individual must
find a mate this can be difficult for
populations that have a low number of
individuals or where the individual are
very widespread that can sometimes make
sexual reproduction difficult also
sexual reproduction is not as fast as
asexual reproduction
in most cases the generation time is the
time between consecutive generations for
organisms that reproduce sexually the
generation time is typically longer for
example in human populations the
generation time is about 20 to 30 years
between generations with asexual
reproduction however it's much more
rapid bacteria can divide and reproduce
very very quickly
for example the generation time of E
coli in good conditions is as little as
20 minutes
in fact e coli cells can start a second
round of binary fission before the first
round has even finished and so it's a
much more rapid process which can lead
to great numbers in a short amount of
time now one more thing to think about
why is this variety important why is the
increased genetic variety from sexual
reproduction a pro and why is the
reduced genetic variety from asexual
reproduction a con well it's because
genetic variety is what allows natural
selection to occur and what eventually
leads to evolution that is because
organisms are often living in
environments that can change and in some
cases environments that can change very
rapidly so when you have a population of
organisms with increased genetic variety
you'll find that some individuals in
those populations are more equipped to
handle the change in environment which
allows the population overall to survive
but the more beneficial genetic
variations will spread through a
population over time and this change
over time is evolution whenever you have
reduced genetic variety
whenever the genetic for
is based solely on random mutations
organisms are dependent on having the
right mutations for the environment at
that given time and if they don't have
the correct mutations it will allow them
to survive in a changing environment
then the populations could die out of
course if they do have the jet variety
necessary then again you would see
beneficial genetic mutations being able
to spread through a population over time
and that change over time leads to
evolution so that is the difference
between asexual and sexual reproduction
I hope you learned a lot from watching
biology professor and we'll see you next
time